bonjour Sophie merci d'être venu me lire
se dévoiler pour faire tomber les
préjugés ce mercredi 18 octobre se
tenait la première édition des
bibliothèques vivantes à la médiathèque
du canal de Montini le Bretonneux une
rencontre entre des personnes atteintes
de handicap psychique et le grand
publicque autour de la métaphore du
livre le malade raconte un chapitre de
son histoire suivi d'un temps d'échange
un concept pour ouvrir la différence
questionner pour avoir moins peur le
rétablissement des
personnes c'est pas juste son affaire à
lui je pense que c'est l'affaire du
collectif c'est l'affaire de tous de
chaque citoyen si on est dans une
démarche d'inclusion euh il faut qu'on
puisse accueillir quelqu'un qui souffre
d'un trouble quelquil soit du coup
c'était ma dernière hospitalisation ça
remonte à plus de 7 ans depuis
l'adolescence edvig souffre de troubles
bipolairirees alternance entre
dépression et phase euphorique une
pathologie RV élé à l'âge de 28 ans
après de nombreuses années d'érance
diagnostique cet espace d'expression lui
permet de libérer la parole les
personnes étaient très ému face à ce que
je pouvais leur raconter
et donc voilà ça m'a ça m'a touché aussi
elles sont beaucoup dans l'écoute et
beaucoup dans l'échange et vraiment
enfin c'est c'est agréable quoi ça
permet de nous confronter à d'autres
choses à élargir notre notre façon de
voir le monde et et de voir les autres
aussi quoi ce jour-là 11 usagers du
centre médico-psychologique à sain-cir
ou de l'hôpital de jour Eugène Bleuler à
Versailles ont livré leurs histoires de
prochaines édition pourrai être organisé
dans des universités ou des festivals
l'espoir de pouvoir enfin lire en
l'autre comme dans un livre ouvert